dr mercola thanks for coming on today
one of my questions would just be around
uh fda approval i know you've mentioned
previously that these vaccines were not
fda approved and there's been some
things in the news specifically even up
to the white house where they said these
vaccines were fda approved can you just
talk a little bit about the confusion
there on august 23rd
pfizer met in a close meeting with the
fda there was no advisory panel no
external experts there to to watch or
take minutes or present
but what came out of that meeting was a
continuation of the emergency use
authorization to pfizer so pfizer was
not approved by the fda
and then there was a biological
licensing agreement assigned to
bioentech a german partner for their
vaccine
but that
application must have a commitment to
post marketing studies many post
marketing studies about myocardial
injury after the vaccines heart injury
myocarditis special language about
safety and pregnancy and so if bioentech
wants to move forward with a product if
the german company wants to enter the us
market they have to do all that and
commit to that they have to write a
package insert and then bioentech would
have to you know produce a product and
distribute the united states that hasn't
happened so pfizer is still under the
emergency use authorization americans
know pfizer is not approved because the
consent form didn't change and insurance
companies don't have to approve it
insurance companies are not paying for
it it's still the same old pfizer
and the consent forms simply say that we
don't know if this is going to work and
we don't know if it's safe that consent
forms are asking americans to
participate in research and that's what
the emergency use authorization is so
there was a false talking point that
came out of that meeting and went all
the way up to the president united
states who said that pfizer was approved
when it was not and you know within
seven days uh dr gruber who signed the
letter for bioentech uh the you know the
high ranking vaccine regulatory official
she resigned so if that tells you
anything so my question is around the
testing right so we've seen places like
kroger and walgreens they've actually
increased the price of their tests from
14 to 24 in your professional opinion is
that just based on supply and demand or
is there a bigger thing going on there
it's supply and demand everyone's got
covered 19 now i think almost all my
patients do there's almost complete
capitulation we heard reports out of
california yesterday that even if people
test positive they should show up to
work anyway because it's just it's so
ubiquitous now
so what i'm telling my patients if i
have a high risk
senior citizen i'm really wanting to
know if it's covered or not i'll have
them get tested but we should be doing
zero tests on people without symptoms
because it's just it's it's never been
fda approved to do that it's not
supported by any of the science it's not
supported by who or cdc that means all
the testing in schools or employers
making people do tests once a week
travel
crossing the border all that needs to
stop immediately it's a giant waste of
testing we know when people are
asymptomatic and they test positive 97
of the time it's a false positive that's
what's going on in the nfl the nba
all the sports teams nhl right now is
they're just generating tons of of test
results and having people quarantined
for no reason the cdc finally
capitulated on that too and said even if
you test positive uh you could go to a
five-day quarantine period uh in
you know that's if you're asymptomatic
we've gone ahead and extended that to um
to clinically uh you know clinically
patients with covet 19
illness provided the last two days they
had don't have a fever or severe
symptoms so i think a lot of this is
just breaking down with omicron omicron
is so ubiquitous it doesn't respond to
the vaccines everyone's getting it it
broke through natural immunity it broke
through vaccine immunity
and it's like getting a it's like
getting a common cold